I think that a lot of the things that
people hear about podcasts that they
love sound like innate talents and
they're actually just learned skills you
know like reporting certainly is
something you learn interviewing is
certainly something that you learn and
the nice thing for people who love
listening to stuff is like a lot of the
learning is just listening to things you
like and internalizing what works or
wondering what works I feel like we've
been lucky Alex and I we came in as such
amateurs and we've gotten to be in a
context where there's a lot of training
and there's a lot of good people which
makes me think that yeah like anybody
could do it but it's hard and it takes
like a long time to make a very little
bit and it takes a lot of work to make
something that sounds like kind of fun
and easy for radio producers the thing
that is the fundamental unique thing
about it I think is that we really
really think about it tape first like
you had a two-hour interview with
somebody they said they there were three
moments that were really funny and then
they told you one good story and then
they described one thing that really
create a picture in your head that is
gonna be huge story like you're gonna
take those pieces of tape you're gonna
lay them out and all the writing is
really secondary to that where it's like
what are the what kind of writing can
get me through these pieces of tape that
I want to play for the listener and it's
just funny because I think radio like
when radio writing is good it feels like
good writing and so when you're
listening to it you don't realize how
much for most people anyway the tapes
driving it but that's really like for
instance one of the things we're always
worrying about in our stories is can we
make sure that we get surprised by
things on tape like if alex is reporting
something is there a way that we could
have an editorial process where he'll
tell me about it in the Edit room on
tape and I won't know about it prior to
that it's a lot of just like making sure
things happen as sound so when I first
started editing my own radio pieces the
hardest part was listening to the sound
of my own voice I hated it
it's a normal human way that people
should feel about themselves now it's
not that I just don't care it's just
it's just a thing that exists for me now
the thing that's hardest about it is
hearing all my mistakes like listening
to an interview and thinking you idiot
if you would just set it that way or if
you've just been listening a little bit
more carefully you would have something
really good here and instead you're
gonna have to work for three hours to
find a way to salvage the little piece
that you got but for me that's why it's
really valuable for us at least on our
show for people to edit themselves is
you know radio always feels like very
much the art of the possible you go out
there you record a bunch of stuff some
of it's good some of it's not some of
it's going to need writing a lot of its
going to get discarded but by editing
yourself you hear all the moments that
could that you might have a better
chance of improving next time